Okay. Well, good morning, everybody.
Thank you for joining our session.
And so I want to
bring your attention to this slide here.
If you're interested, please scan the QR code if you want to ask
questions and other features during the session.
So we'll leave it up for a couple of
seconds or minutes,
just so you have a chance to take
your pictures.
We have our experts at the monitor that are monitoring who still has
their phones up. And once the phones are down, we're going to go on
to the next slide. All right. Well, good. Thank you.
Okay, so I'm just going to give you a little quick introduction to the area.
So the Y chromosome in cancer, why does it matter?
It's one of these understudied chromosomes.
There's a lot of history
of GWAS studies that have really ignored the Y
chromosome.
And it's really emerging as a significant cancer marker,
and you'll hear about that today, associated with increased risk of
aggressive
cancer development
and mortality.
It has major bearings when it's lost in cancer on
immune response
of the host and also therapeutics.
It's definitely involved in aging.
It is progressively lost with normal aging.
And finally, because of the issues with
therapeutics and its role as a marker of
risk, it has potentially significant role in
the diagnosis, risk assessment, and therapeutics in precision
medicine. And loss of Y is really not new.
It's been
known to occur in cancer since 1963,
and roughly about 40% of cancers
have that. And for those of you that are looking for CME
credits, this session has 1.5. So
we have three speakers today.
And we're all going to give complimentary
talks on various aspects of the Y chromosome
in cancer. And so I'd like to introduce the first speaker,
Lars Forsberg, all the way from Sweden. Please come up.
Hello.
Thank you, Dan, for this introduction,
and for organizing this great session, and for inviting me.
Happy to be here. So my talk will focus on hematopoietic
loss of Y.
And as Dan mentioned, this has been known for a very long time,
but it was long thought of as phenotypically neutral.
But about 12 years ago, we published this paper showing that men with loss of
Y in their circulating blood cells have an increased risk for all-cause mortality
and cancer.
So
this is an outline of my talk today.
So I will give you a very broad
background for you who are new to this field.
So I will cover what it is, its prevalence in
normal aging men,
associations with diseases, something about the disease
mechanisms that we have unraveled so far,
relevance for cancer.
But we'll start up with the shorter lives of men because this is not talked about
very much, right? Not enough, I think.
So
on this slide, you see the life expectancy of men and
women in the entire world.
So if there were no difference in life expectancy, all the dots would be on the
black line in the middle.
But they're not. So globally, men are expected to live or
we have five years shorter lifespans on average.
This is a huge difference.
And you think, "Ah, I know why," right?
Because men are men,
and we do things. We bring the electric sandwich grill to the
pool party,
and we know this is bad for survival, but we still do it.
Internet is full of evidence why men live shorter lives,
right?
And
there are some truths to this picture.
So here I show you the global causes of death among men
and women, crude data. And in green, you see the accidents and that
men are over-represented there. But the reason I'm showing you this slide
is this very important difference
between women and men. From 20 to about 80, men
are over-represented.
So men die from common disease at younger ages compared with women.
We don't age as well as you do. So the question is, why?
This has been known for centuries, actually, and many
hypotheses have been discussed, including genetic differences, and recently
we added the Y chromosome loss to this list.
So loss of Y is a during lifetime acquired
mutation. It happens during
mitotic errors leading to aneuploidic cells with
having these 45,X0 karyotype, right?
So for single cells,
that we study at least, this is a binary event.
The entire Y chromosome is lost.
So it's not the same as microdeletions
or other
variants that will be covered later on this
sessionBut typically, this
missegregation leads to these cells.
And interestingly, you have cells with the same karyotype,
losing one of the sex chromosomes in females leads to
45,X0 karyotype as well, right? And if this occurs
very early, it's a risk factor for Turner syndrome.
It's one of the mutations associated with Turner syndrome.
But it could also be acquired later during life as the Y loss
that we study.
And then it's
called LOX, and you can read about it in that paper that I
show here.
But moving back to the Y chromosome loss.
So when this occurs in the hematopoietic stem cells pool, it will
create mosaicism in blood
because some cells will still carry the Y chromosome while others are Loy
cells.
So in different individuals, we'll see different levels of mosaic
loss of Y. In some very high levels, up to 80% we've seen,
and in others, much lower.
So this creates a problem when we want to talk about prevalence, right?
Because who has loss of Y if it looks like this?
So you have to define a threshold in this continuum, and, for
example, by using 5% threshold and applying that to UK
Biobank, we see that at study entry,
20% of these individuals
in the UK Biobank had loss of Y in more than 5% of their blood
cells
going into this study.
That's a high number, and you see how it increases with age, right?
It's almost linear.
So if you think about it, in this age span,
there is more than 10 million men in the UK.
And if UK Biobank is representative for the
UK population, that would imply that we have two million men
in the UK with loss of Y in more than 5% of their blood cells.
And looking in
later studies in other biobanks and cohorts, you see
very similar prevalence of loss of Y.
It varies between ethnicities and so forth, but roughly
quite similar.
Depends also on technologies and stuff.
But if we combine this with data on demographics
globally, and how many men you have in different age ranges in the
world today, and you combine this data,
we have an estimation that about two to
400 million men globally have loss of Y in more than 5% of their blood
cells. It's a very high number, right?
But it's probably much more than that because
when we look in single-cell data,
we see loss of Y cells in all individuals,
every man.
So we can use
single-cell data to detect loss of Y in single cells.
Different types of single-cell data have been done.
So basically,
if you do single-cell RNAseq data, for example, the lack of expression of
specific MSY genes that are
present only on the male-specific part of the Y chromosome, we
can say which cells are Loy cells and not, here shown in red.
And so far, as I mentioned, all studied men and tissues that has
been studied, you find these Loy cells.
So it's extremely prevalent. And
not only that, that we all have it,
it also occurs multiple times
within individuals during lifetime.
So in this beautiful picture from Mitchell and colleagues, published in
"Nature" a few years back, they studied 10 donors,
and sampled hematopoietic stem cells from them and grew them from
single-cell colonies and did quite low-pass whole genome
sequencing and reconstructed these phylogenies of their
hematopoietic cells.
As for example,
I show only the data on loss of Y here in this presentation, but so in
a 38-year-old man, they found one
clone
without the Y chromosome.
And
in older individuals that they sampled, they found these 19
clones here, as shown. Maybe you can see this,
right? I don't have it.
Doesn't work. Anyway.
And if you look in this oldest man, they found 62
independent loss of Y events
in this guy.
So amazing he was still alive, right?
But
for the majority of these clones, Loy was the
sole driver of this clonal hematopoiesis.
But as you can also appreciate, sometimes loss of Y occurs with other
so-called CHIP driver mutations.
So
there's a discussion in the field whether CHIP mutations, these are clonal
hematopoiesis of indeterminate potential,
which is also age-related and associated with diseases.
But whether loss of Y co-occurs is a risk
factor for
CHIP or vice versa, this is really not established yet.
Seems like some CHIP mutations are associated with loss of Y,
others not. So we'll know more in future work, I think,
about this.
So
talking about risk factors, the established ones are the
age, of course, as I mentioned, smoking and other exposures are very high risk
factors, but also germline genetic predisposition.
So we identified more than 150 genomic loci that
increase risk for loss of Y by GWAS, and these risk
loci are close to genes important for genomic instability, cell cycle regulation,
and so forth. So it makes sense.
So as Don mentioned in his talk, it's been known
since this paper in '63 that loss of Y is a very frequent event in the
hematopoietic system of aging men.But it was long thought that it was
phenotypically neutral.
But this was
overruled by this paper that we had.
So we basically found this
by looking in a cohort of aging men called
ULSAM.
Quite small cohort, but had some benefits.
The individuals was kind of old, and we had very long follow-up
times.
So here we identified that men with loss of Y in more than one-third of their blood
cells had
survival only half as long as other men.
So in addition to all-cause mortality, we also
identified increased risk for cancer.
So both cancer mortality overall and solid tumors.
And this has been replicated quite well during the last decade, I would
say. Many papers coming out in different types of cancers.
So this is all loss of Y in blood and increased risk for cancers.
So as you can see, it's both
male specific cancers and
non-sex specific cancers,
and also hematological malignancies.
So in this part of the presentation,
I think it's good to mention that I will not talk about what
Ester and Dan will cover, is kind of the loss of
Y in the cancer cells, which is also extremely frequent.
So you will see this slide with better resolution soon and discussed by, in
Ester's presentation. And I guess Dan will show you this.
I will not spoil too much, but it's very important
in tumor biology, of course.
So in addition to blood and cancer genomes,
loss of Y is also common in other tissues, it appears.
So it's enriched in microglia in Alzheimer patients and
in the kidney of chronic kidney disease patients.
And recently we showed this in idiopathic
pulmonary fibrosis, that LOY cells is present in all lineages collected
from these lungs of patients and controls, actually.
So it's all over the place.
So adding IPF to this list,
actually, the risk
for all major causes of
death is associated with loss of Y, including the biggest killers,
cardiovascular diseases, including myocardial infarction.
So how can loss of Y in blood increase risk for disease in other organs?
So we think about this
basically in two main
hypothesis or mechanisms. These indirect disease mechanisms,
where different risk factors increase genomic instability, that
over time will lead to loss of Y leukocytes, as well as disease in other
organs. So these are then independent processes.
But we also think of direct disease mechanisms,
where this mutation will lead to functional effects of these immune cells that
are studied in the blood, which will lead to compromised immune
functions and disease in other organs.
So this indirect disease mechanism has been very
nicely shown that this exists. For example, if you use a polygenic risk score
for loss of Y and apply this for females, you can predict risk for breast
cancer and also age at menopause.
So
just mentioning this, that shared genetic predisposition for loss of Y and
disease helps explain how LOY in blood is associated with disease in
other organs
in an independent fashion.
So moving to the direct disease mechanisms.
So the Y chromosome was very long viewed as a genetic
wasteland,
only important for sex determination and sperm production.
But an emerging view is that it
contains more than 100 genes. Twenty-eight of them are
expressed in wild type leukocytes.
But it also contains a lot of other functional contents of different types.
So losing this entire chromosome should be
viewed as a super mutation or something.
It's not that you just have a point mutation that shift the expression of, or
the function of a protein. You lose an entire chromosome and all the
content on it. So a lot of things happening in these cells.
So we and others have studied this, what happens in these cells.
And
I don't have time to go through it all, but hundreds of autosomal
genes change their expression in cells without the Y chromosome.
And this is in a cell type specific manner.
So stuff goes on in these cells, but how to study, is this really
proof of causality? No. So to study this, we teamed up
with Kenneth Walsh at UVA.
And he and his lab, they
generated
LOY mice using CRISPR, with guide RNA targeting the
centromere on Y,
and could show then that loss of Y in these mice,
that loss of Y is causally
related to reduced lifespan. So this is a very important result
because
it
shows that it's not just
aging associated or a side effect of
aging or something like that. It's causal.
So in addition to that important result, we identified the disease
mechanism, which is the increased fibrosis and compromised cardiac
function. So this is published, so I will just skip very
quickly through this.
But basically, when you have loss of Y in macrophages, you get increased
fibrosis by this TGF-beta signaling.
And by applying TGF-beta inhibitors, we could reverse the LOY
induced phenotypes.
So in parallel, my team, Yonatan and Jonas, showed similar phenotypes
in men in UK Biobank.
And as I said, you can look this paper up if you want to
know about the details.So
we established there that loss of Y have functional effects, leads to
fibrosis in other organs. And more recently, we
published a paper showing that loss of Y also
causes those immune cells with the loss of Y to have a disrupted
immunosuppveillance.
So basically, that will lead to the accumulation of senescent or old
cells.
And this is also relevant for cancer because LOY drives
inflammation, tissue remodeling, and fibrosis by
upregulation of
these immune checkpoint receptors.
So
inhibitors for PD-1, for example, we can reverse the
LOY induced effect here as well.
So that was results from mice, and we also see similar
in men.
So it's showing you three papers here that you have increased
TGF-beta signaling in circulating LOY
monocytes.
And I just want to mention Josephine's work here.
Josephine is a PhD student in my lab, looking at pulmonary
fibrosis that I mentioned before.
So about 80% of the male access in UK Biobank occurs in the
group of men with LOY and IPF patients and
undiagnosed people in UK Biobank with LOY had reduced lung functions.
And by reanalysis of five single-cell data sets,
we could reconstruct the disease mechanism
discovered in mice that these LOY macrophages leads to
increased profibrotic signaling, leading to enhanced
extracellular matrix production, fibrosis, scarring of tissues, and
exacerbation of this
disease.
So what about other disease? So fibrosis contributes to the majority of human
disease, cardiovascular, cancers, and dementias in different
ways.
So in oncology, tumor fibrosis is
desmoplasia, basically, a collagen-rich fibrous reaction,
creating this stiff TMA associated with patient outcomes and
important for therapy and immune system functions.
So we've been trying to look into this. It was much harder than I thought.
Basically, tumor heterogeneity is not easy because this
desmoplasia will create this desmoplastic
front. So it's not homogeneous over the tumor, typically.
So we're still working on this. And
this year there was this paper published showing that if you have loss of
Y in tumor cells,
in this case,
you had more collagen, which is kind of a proxy for this desmoplasia.
So more loss of Y in the cancer, more
fibrotic tumors. We don't know really yet
how to
move forward with this. Or we do, actually, but we will
try to work with these new spatial technologies.
Here you see the yellow is fibronectin.
It's a desmoplastic front, basically, and you see the cell segmentations.
So I think we need to go kind of zoom in quite a lot in
tissues to identify the LOY cells in this level.
We have already done. So this is based on the
COSMIC's
data.
And
you can see here the LOY in red and fibrosis in green in the
renal cancer, and that there is an association, but we don't know if it's loss of Y
in tumors or immune cells. But in coming experiments, we will be able to
show that, I hope.
So
I just want to
back up a little and
show you my estimation of how many male deaths that
LOY might cause, actually. So this is, again, data from UK Biobank, 15 years after
study entry. How many men and women, and men with and
without LOY, that was still alive or had died?
And you see the percentages there, and you plot it like this.
So then you see that the
LOY men are quite overrepresented, right?
And
this first part, if you split up the mortality of these men with
loss of Y, I would say that this part that I show here, it's kind
of mortality that is sex neutral and shared with women, and
also encompass these indirect disease mechanisms.
Then you have this increased male mortality not related to loss of Y, the other
factors that I briefly introduced before.
So men without loss of Y
also have an increased risk for mortality compared with women, right?
But as you see, the remaining part here, so
50% of this,
is not explained by the other factors.
So this would translate to about 1,400 deaths in the UK
Biobank or 6% at that time point. And if you
use that number on the UK and the world, you see,
of course, there's a lot of assumptions here, and it's not directly
translatable, but still, this gives an indication that this is
without the indirect effects. So this is the part
where LOY would be causal,
I would argue.
So this will then LOY help explain why men dies
younger and have diseases at younger
ages compared to women.
So I hope you agree with me that LOY is very
common. And I hope I convinced you that hundreds of
millions of men are affected.
And it is associated with all major causes of death, including cancers.
And assuming that the causal mechanisms are similar to those in mice, more than a
million male deaths every year would be caused by loss of Y.
And I think-As a community,
I really
hope that you
see the potential here for clinical utility, and I think it will be discussed
in the coming sessions as well. But patient stratifications,
the repurposing of drugs that already exist, which
patients should have this anti-fibrotic treatment, like in cancers, it's still
used, but
not with regards to loss of Y. So patients with Y loss in tumors and immune
cells would probably respond much better, and you will see some data supporting
this. But I think it's time for clinical utility.
I want to thank my group members shown here, also other collaborators
and my funders.
And with that,
I
have
end of time. So thank you very much. I'm ready for your questions.
Great. Fabulous talk. Okay, we'll open it up for questions.
Does the loss of Y coincide with genomic
instability in general? That there's more instability across the whole genome?
Can you speak a little closer?
Do you think the loss of Y is related to genomic instability in general
across the whole genome?
Yeah.
Yeah?
If
you
have loss of Y, you have
more genomic instability. But yes, that's the short answer, yes.
So which comes first, the loss of Y or the
instability overall?
As I
showed you, this germline, we inherit certain variants from mother
and father, right? And certain variants that you inherit will
give you increased risk for genomic instability.
So you have that as you go on, but then you also have the somatic mutations
occurring during lifetime, right?
That adds to that, and you have an overlap between the germline and the
somatic mutations
to create this genomic instability somatically.
And
as a result of that and other risk factors, aging, smoking and stuff,
you will have loss of Y. So loss of Y will be a result of the genomic instability
for sure, right?
Right. Thank you.
If that was your question. Thanks.
Thank you.
My question was about the IPF. I think that's very
interesting.
And we know that some of the IPF is also inherited,
right? There's some genes that
increase that risk, and then there's also the short telomere syndrome, the telomere
biology disorders. Have you looked at that in a cohort,
the IPF cohort that you
investigated for the loss of Y?
Thank you.
Thank you. No, I don't think we did.
But would be interesting. Regarding telomeres,
you would expect maybe that the Y chromosome would have very short telomeres
because it's so small chromosome.
So I didn't have time to show you this data, but there's been this
long reading revolution, long read sequencing revolution
with showing that the Y chromosome actually can be up
to 100 megabases. In the reference, it's 60
megabases, right?
But some men have a very short Y chromosome.
From 45 to 100 is kind of where
it is.
Wow.
And by doing telomere sequencing,
the Y chromosome do not have shorter telomeres than other chromosomes,
on the contrary.
Okay.
So that's kind of-
Very interesting.
Yeah.
Cool. Thank you.
Yep.
Thank you. Very nice summary.
So you mentioned the clinical utility.
So you also mentioned
loss of Y is
related to cancer incidence. So
should we consider that for cancer screening?
So now for cancer screening, pretty much we only use age,
right, for the cutoff.
Yeah.
Can we use loss of Y and how?
In the beginning, when I discovered this, I
was like, "Wow, now we can screen, we can cure cancer and everything."
But then when we continued working with this, we see that men with this
mutation, they have increased risk for all major causes of death.
So how would you do this in a clinically relevant way?
If you would screen the general population, you identify a man with loss of Y,
and where should you send him? What should you do?
It's such a broad phenotype
associated with it. I
think
population screening is not the way to go.
I think
because we need much more information.
We have some indications that loss of Y in specific types of immune cells, I didn't
mention this much, but if you have loss of Y in
monocytes, for example, you will have one type of phenotypes
associated with it. But if you have it in T cells, you will have other types, maybe
cancer.
So then the screening tool would need to be able to
distinguish which cell type that has loss of Y, and then it becomes quite
complicated and expensive. But for sure, I hope in the future that we
are able to use this to guide at least treatment options, right?
If you have loss of Y in immune cells and/or in tumors,
you would benefit more from
specific treatments, immune checkpoint and blockades and all that.
So definitely for
stratification of patients, for sure.
In the future, maybe screening, but I
think it will be kind of difficult for that reason that you...
But we'll see what happens.
Yeah.
I think basically now we don't have
good indicators for screening for more
cost-effective screening, so we only use age.
I would argue age is not perfect at all, but I
was thinking how can we use this? Basically, then, as you
said, how we measure this, right? What's going to be the
cutoff? Yeah.
Yeah.
I get that. Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you.
Hello. Thank you so much for your talk. One quick question.
So regarding the IPF and the loss of Y,
I wonder if you have looked into
whether there are differences in terms of the loss
of Y hematopoietic cell population inside
the IPF tissue regarding the stage
and extent of the disease for the IPF,
whether there's-
Yeah
... a relationship to it.
Yeah, definitely. So I
just rushed through that.
So
those single-cell RNAseq data sets that we reanalyzed, they were kind
of
like a mix of cells from the pulmonary tissue.
So in there you also had the infiltrating immune cells.
So if you look in that, you see that the loss of Y occurs mostly
in these M2 type of macrophages, which are the pro-fibrotic ones.
But we also found some very interesting and
kind of
unsuspected result. For example, the fibroblasts in
the lungs of IPF patients had like 20% loss of
Y.
Mm-hmm.
Much higher in the controls. And that we didn't really
understand and we didn't really...
But, there's a need to kind of
characterize the prevalence of loss of Y
in
all types of tissues and organs, because it's not only in
the cancer genomes, it's not only in the hematopoietic stem
cells and the blood cells in the immune system.
It seems like it's all over the place, but we don't know
how prevalent it is in other tissues.
But this is a need that we need to fill.
So it's been found also in the early stage IPF,
too, those loss of Y, if you have looked into?
I don't know if we...
No, we didn't have that data, I think.
But we see in
UK Biobank,
there was this lung function data,
FVC and
carbon dioxide, I think, these two.
And even before you have an IPF
diagnosis, you see that men with loss of Y have a reduced lung function.
So I would suspect that also early onset cases
would be worth looking into. We didn't do that.
But that would be interesting.
Thank you.
Okay.
Great. Thank you very much, Lars.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
So,
what I'm going to discuss today really actually relates to some of the questions
that were asked, which is really wonderful,
that we can really complement the talks this way.
And so, you've heard a lot and Lars did me a huge favor
because he went over beautifully about the background.
So I'm not going to have to spend a lot of time on this.
Obviously, cancer and both normal biology and cancer has
a lot of dimorphism both because of chromosomes,
and hormones. And he showed very nicely,
there's another study showing that the incidence of cancer is much higher in
males than in females from an AARP
study. Similarly, mortality, I don't think after
Lars' talk I need to convince you of this,
is significantly higher. So,
my area that I've spent the last 30 years or so working on
is bladder cancer. I'm a urologic oncologist,
and I've done most of my research in bladder, which is now
extending to other tumor types. And one of the things that has always
fascinated me about bladder cancer are some of the things
that are on this slide.
So it's quite common, but pertaining to today's discussion,
we have a significant male to female incidence
difference.
And also interestingly enough,
actually when you adjust for stage, grade, and other risk factors of
disease progression,
you have women actually do less well than men.
And generally a disease of aging, it's associated with smoking, and
we treat with immunotherapy and chemotherapy.
And I put those in red because they're relevant to the findings
that I'm going to show you. So,
we've been interested in this sexual dimorphism bladder cancer for a very long
time, and we worked on androgens in bladder and other things,
that could potentially explain it.
And we're getting more and more interested in chromosomes,
and because of some observations that we made relating
to specific markers on chromosome
Y,
and other bladder cancer features.
But this paper came across
in 2018, and it really got us seriously thinking
about
the roles of chromosomes
in bladder cancer. Let's see. You see the mouse? Yeah.
GreatWhat you see here is the use of the
four-core genotype mouse, and
this is a very, very powerful mouse.
And what it does is it allows you to really study
different chromosomal complements,
basically discordant from their phenotypes.
So, for example, at the very ends, you have XX females
and XY males. So those are normal mice, basically.
But in the middle, you see what you have is XY females and
XX males. And basically, this is essentially a
transgenic where the SRY gene has been moved to an autosome.
And what we do in bladder cancer is we use this experimental
system called BBN carcinogen. It's a carcinogen that is
a very potent form of carcinogens that are found in tobacco
smoke. And bladder cancer, for some of you that may not know this,
is actually a tobacco-related cancer, although it's not intuitively obvious.
But what you do, you smoke, you absorb the carcinogen, it clears in the
urine, and then it sits there in the bladder, which is a storage
vesicle, and basically exposes the urothelium to
carcinogens. So this model is actually quite good for
muscle-invasive bladder cancer, which is the most serious form of the
disease. And when you induce mice
with BBN, you generate these Kaplan-Meier curves,
and you see that females
get it later, males get it sooner. Eventually, all the mice
die from this, so this Kaplan-Meier curve is cut off.
But essentially from this paper, the take-home message was that
Y chromosome basically is a bad thing
based on these differences, and androgen
specifically is a bad thing in terms of cancer.
So it seemed to make sense with the literature.
But we looked at this paper and had a
significantly different conclusion.
And the reason is because when you compare XXF,
XYF, sure, the Y chromosome looks like it's
worse, makes things worse. But when you think about it, you
actually lost an X already. And we know from a lot
of literature that there are a number of tumor suppressors on the X
chromosome,
and therefore losing an X is not just like gaining a Y.
It's not equivalent. Furthermore, as you heard from Lars,
Turner syndrome is more prone to cancers,
including bladder cancer. So we came up with the radical hypothesis
that Y may be protective.
And of course, this is Lars' paper that you've seen, which
was to me a real eye-opener,
because it really established that Y chromosome
was really, I think, important in human
disease and specifically cancer and cardiovascular and
neurological disease. And again, it's very common.
The cutoffs
Lars discussed, greater than 10%, I believe in this study,
and others have shown it to be even lower cutoffs as
clinically significant. And again, you've seen this.
I have to tell you, this is one of my favorite slides that I show
when I give this talk because
the joke is when you show Kaplan-Meier curves, you can show them as
long as you put the laser pointer between the two arms.
But I think you put 100 laser pointer dots between these two.
This is pretty obvious. So this is an important finding
in LOI,
in cancer biology, and non-cancer
biology.
So it's related to age. You've seen that as well, very
significantly. And importantly, for many diseases, it's
related to smoking. Interestingly enough, if you stop smoking, your
level of LOI actually gets better.
So an interesting observation. So when
you put all this together,
we came up with a testable
mechanistic model. And the idea is that there's risk
factors, smoking, aging, and some germline
polymorphisms
that basically can induce LOI in PBMCs
and LOI in urothelium, in this case in bladder or other
generic urothelium and epithelial cancers.
And then this could lead to a LOI cancer,
which potentially is more aggressive.
So we started to really dissect this issue and attack it from the
LOI cancer perspective. And so what we did first
is really use a paper that had looked at expression of
the Y genes in various human tissues.
And
here you see urinary bladder.
And we took the genes that were universally
expressed to really construct
18-gene signature in normal human bladder.
And of those, we also were able to do a mouse
signature, which we subsequently used as well.
And we used this signature to show that,
in fact, if you lose loss of Y
in bladder cancer in the TCGA stratified
by the signature, patients with
Y-positive tumors do better than Y-negative tumors.
And bear in mind as well that these
tumors are heterogeneous, but this is really the aggregate result of the
signature value on RNA.
So we then, in a separate paper, we looked at pan-cancer,
and this paper
supported the idea that LOI
was not a favorable outcome in patients with cancer.
This is in all of TCGA. But interestingly, we also found
that there are differences potentially
in how the LOI stratify Asians versus
patients that are Black.And so that was really interesting,
and I really would encourage those of you that are interested in this
to pursue this difference to see if it really pans out.
So then we basically identified a mouse
line that had heterogeneous Y expression,
and we cloned these cells and separated them into positive
Y, if you will, and then cells with negative Y
chromosome, and did a number of in vitro experiments.
And this is just one of many.
And essentially, we didn't find much in vitro.
But what we did find, really, is a significant change
in growth in vivo. And that growth in vivo basically showed that
LOY cells, tumors that were formed from LOY
cells, were much more
aggressive and grew better. And so to make a long story
short, a lot of experiments were done, but this summarizes the take-home
message about the in vivo is when we
hypothesized that the difference could be related to the immune
system because we didn't see much in vitro,
we were able to find something quite interesting, which
is if you use wild-type mice, LOY tumors grow better.
If you use mice that are missing B cells,
LOY grows better. If you use mice that
have no T cells
or no everything, completely
immunocompromised, the tumors generated by
LOY cells grew the same. So that made
us think very strongly that the effect that we noticed and the
aggressiveness that is driving
the LOY is related to the T cell compartment.
So then we did a lot of experiments, and again, I'm not able to show you
all this, but essentially the take-home message was that
when we did either spectral flow or GeoMx proteomics
on CD45
partitions cell components, basically we
noted a significant change with more M2
macrophages as well as more
exhausted T cells. And then the question was: Is
this relevant to human biology? So we used
single-nucleus RNA-seq from a paper we had just published
recently,
and we examined various components in that
single-nucleus RNA data, and we also
noted the same phenomena, which is we had
significantly more T cell exhaustion,
either progenitor or
terminal exhaustion, and this was significantly different
between the two groups
based on the component of the Y or the Y
gene expression. Similarly, for a variety of checkpoint
molecules and checkpoint inhibitors, that was also
tracking very nicely with Y status.
So the take-home message was exhausted T cells,
anti-inflammatory M2 macrophages, overall an
immunosuppressive microenvironment that was created by
the LOY
tumor.
So then the natural question arises, okay, so if you have more
exhaustion, especially potentially reversible exhaustion,
you'd expect these tumors to respond better to checkpoint
inhibitors. And so we add the Y positive or negative
clones that we did before. But in addition to that, to make
sure that we had isogenic lines and we removed the possibility
that this could be a clonal artifact or some sort of clonal selection, we
basically CRISPRed out
the Y chromosome.
And we used the same technology from our
colleague at University of Virginia, Ken Walsh, who was mentioned in the
cardiac study by Lars. He provided us the
construct to do this.
And basically,
what we see here is both in the, what we call in the lab, the
natural LOY lines, Y positive, Y negative
clones here, and the CRISPRed out Y
positive lines that now you can generate a CRISPR knockout
that's missing the Y chromosome. Both of these data
sets showed that LOY
is associated with a better response to checkpoint inhibitors.
So again, like with the single cell
I showed you previously, we wanted to see whether this phenomenon is
actually relevant in people. So we did two things.
We looked at a study called IMvigor210, which is a study
of a PD-L1 inhibitor in advanced bladder cancer, and
stratified the outcome of that data set
using
the signature that
I showed you earlier
for loss of Y
and wild type, and essentially it stratified the
outcome in this data set.
In complement to that, what we did is we collaborated with a company called
Tempus,
that basically had 171 men with bladder
cancer that were treated with PD-1 and PD-L1,
and these are patients all over the US.
There
are multiple
different sequences or treatments they had before.
It's a highly heterogeneous set. It's not a clinical
trial, not controlled at all. Be that as it may, and I think it's
quite significant, the fact that even though the
group is small, the difference was same in
terms of direction, with LOY tumors doing
better with these checkpoint inhibitorsSo
now the question was,
we've answered
some of the aspects of LOI cancer and why potentially it's more
aggressive, which potentially could explain
a lot of the biology, but it made, for the first time, the
point that actually LOI is not an epiphenomenon,
it's not a passenger. It's actually a direct
cause of making cancers more aggressive,
which is why we should all be studying it.
And so the next question was, can we get some evidence
about the role of LOI PBMCs in cancer?
And to do this, we assembled,
from the public domain,
single-cell RNA data. And
this is a description of what this data set has.
And we stratified it by both cancer type
and major cell type. So we had a lot of cells.
And when you see the subsequent slide, the
epithelial is the cancer. So we used a neural network
algorithm to really score the cells based on
Y positive, Y negative,
and then we examined various cell types.
And we came up with a very, very interesting finding.
So when we looked at this single-cell data set, we found
loss of Y within the tumor
occurs in multiple
cell types.
And you could see here, this is human.
These are the cell types here, T cells, B cells, myeloid cells.
I think I want to emphasize the point, and a very important point that Lars made,
fibroblasts have LOI, and both in the tumor,
suggesting that potentially we have fibrotic components that can
contribute to the tumor progression,
and endothelium.
And then what we did is we examined single-cell
RNA data from our mouse studies with the BBN model that
I showed you earlier.
And interestingly enough, the BBN model, which is again, a very
faithful reproduction of a human muscle-invasive bladder cancer,
shows trends in the same cells. The other thing that
was quite interesting is the fact that there seems to be an
enrichment of LOI normal cells with LOI
cancer cells. You can see from this heat map that there is an
enrichment. So LOI cells like each other for
some reason, and they tend to aggregate
in the same tumors.
So we then looked at the correlation
to explore this further between LOI in tumor-infiltrating
lymphocytes on the Y-axis and LOI in PBMCs.
And you note that for both B cells and T cells,
there is a shift in the data to the left
side, suggesting that there is an enrichment in
patients that have LOI in PBMCs and enrichment
of these Y negative cells in the tumor.
So again, you can start putting two and two together and seeing that
there is a trend and maybe give you some clues why
actually having PBMCs with LOI
in a cancer situation could make the cancer worse.
But does it really make the cancer worse?
So the question is, what cells are doing what?
And if you lose LOI in benign cells.
And so
we examined our various populations and
noted that it was the T cells, both CD8 and CD4,
that sustained the largest transcriptional
consequences of the loss of Y.
But you see there are other cells here that also have, again, fibroblasts,
monocytes, and K cells. All the things that you heard by
Lars also are significantly affected.
And the T cells, again, there's no exact pattern for
both CD4 or CD8 T cells, but
the themes of exhaustion
and signaling emerge. So clearly these cells have been
disrupted in their function. And I'm going to skip to really the
punchline at the end, which is when we actually
stratify the components of
CD4 and CD8 in the context of the
large TCGA group of 4,000 male patients, we noted
that when you have both a negative LOI, so basically a LOI
cancer,
and a LOI CD4, the lines are
red
in this case, and similar for CD8. When you don't have LOI
for either the cancer or
the T cells, the lines are blue
for both. So that basically told us that the
benign component that has LOI is basically
very, very important, and it likely tracks from
the PBMCs. So in the last minute,
I'm going to show you one preliminary data that's now in
a journal in revision
that basically attempts to answer the question
of what is the role of LOI in normal epithelium.
So
bladder cancer is a field change, a field cancerization.
So when a bladder exposed to all these carcinogen has many
recurrences
of various areas in the bladder, when you have a recurrent tumor,
and that's because the epithelium is really damaged.
It's very much like a lung.
And so what we did isWe used
data from a study that had been previously published where they took
bladders with bladder cancer, and they broke it up into various
cubes.
And then we mapped loss of Y
in these cubes. And the black here shows urothelial
carcinoma. You see the geography. It's like a map.
Bladder, basically you turn a round bladder into
a flat surface. And then we look at the Y signature.
And I think this is one of several data sets
that we have in this manuscript.
But essentially what it shows you is that LOY does happen
in premalignant lesions.
And as the premalignant lesion gets worse, you have
basically progressive loss of the Y chromosome, suggesting
that
LOY in a non-hematopoietic system,
specifically this is a epithelial, obviously, system, is
also quite significant and potentially a marker of
early disease.
So with that,
I'd like to conclude.
So what we've seen so far is tremendous potential, I think,
and you'll hear more from Esther in a minute.
LOY has definite prevention chops, and we're looking at
some of the drivers of LOY that
potentially could cause LOY in a variety of cells.
The issue of biomarkers came up in the questions,
both for risk assessment of cancer development, but also for
response to therapy, such as checkpoint inhibitors.
And finally,
are there different ways that we can inhibit and destroy LOY
cancer cells? So a lot of really exciting stuff that
we can pursue here in this field. And this is perhaps the most
important slide.
These are all the collaborators and folks in my lab that have
contributed to these two papers that I presented.
And I've been very lucky that the American people, all of you that
pay taxes,
have supported my work through the NCI funding.
So thank you very much.
Okay.
Any questions?
Thank
you very much.
This is not working. Can you hear me?
It's working.
Yeah, it's fine. So
I have two related questions. In the
context where you see that the LOY tumors, they respond better to checkpoint
blockade,
have you done longitudinal analysis and tested the
frequency of LOY,
like in the tumors that are resisting? Do you see it increasing?
Yes.
Yeah.
We
have a manuscript that we're putting together exactly with that.
Because also, the second question is because the Y
chromosome, the Y antigens, have been the real models for immune tolerance
in mouse and human.
There is a really strong selection of T cells against the Y antigens.
I was wondering if you see any correlation between the presence
of Y reactive T cells in the blood and the loss of
Y in healthy individuals. Could this be
immune-driven?
You see my questions on that?
No, repeat the question.
So the Y antigens, they are delete-- They are
driving-
Missing
... immune tolerance in the thymines.
And I was wondering if escape of some reactive T
cells could drive the loss
of Y in somatic cells, and whether you see increased
frequencies of Y reactive T cells in the blood of the
male-
Yeah
... where the LOY is high.
Yeah. That's a really great question. And we've looked at that.
We're looking at that very actively now.
There seems to be a definite communication
between the cancer cell and the non-cancer
component. We showed that in the second paper,
and we're pursuing that very actively.
We have some potential, very interesting clues of how that may
happen.
Okay.
But I think that cell-cell communication is true,
I think, in our models, and we've done several models now.
Cool. Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks.
Okay.
No more questions. Thank you. So Esther, please come up.
Thank you so much, Dan, for inviting me to the session.
Thank you, everyone, for your interest in the Y chromosome.
It's still, as the previous speakers have said, sort of an
underdeveloped field, and I think it really deserves more interest than it
currently has right now in the community.
So I will talk about Y chromosome loss specifically as a driver of
cancer. And recognizing that I was the third in the session,
I skipped some of the background, but I'll still introduce a little bit
of what I'm going to talk about, of course. So let's see.
Okay, these are my disclosures.
Okay, so just going back to the structure of the Y chromosome, because it's going
to be important for what I'm going to talk about.
The X and Y chromosome, as you know, sort
of have shared evolutionary
ancestry, and that means that there are still some,
and I think this pointer is not working, some genes that are present on
both the X and Y chromosome. And so conveniently, many of them are actually
labeled as X or Y versions, such as ZFX
and ZFY. We already heard about KDM6A, which is also called
UTX, and then the homologue UTY, and then
KDM5D and KDM5C on the X and Y chromosomes.
So why would this be important? Because if you have loss of Y chromosome,
which you heard is very common, then we lose one of these copies
that actually should be expressed from both chromosomes in body
cells.And so this is just another version of a
gene expression of these Y chromosome genes across different tissues.
And you can see that
some of the genes actually ubiquitously expressed across all
tissues, and not just in the testes or during male development, as
maybe was initially thought. So really, the relevance of the Y chromosome at
this point, I don't have to convince you, but really carries forward
through development and aging across all tissues.
So Y is much less studied than other chromosomes, and this is particularly
true for the cancer genomics field.
The cancer genomics field was revolutionized through short read sequencing
maybe 15 years ago, and there were many studies that came out and sort of
discovered genetic alterations, mutations, structural variants, copy number
alterations across tumor types. But what most
of the tools that were developed at the time could not do is properly
analyze the X and Y chromosome, which has to do with the fact that
the X and Y chromosome in males violates
the diploid assumption. So many tools were
around, and lots of studies were done, including, of course, from the Cancer
Genome Atlas, and this is actually a heat map
from the Cancer Genome Atlas that really had large impact.
And you can see the X and Y chromosomes are missing.
So we have no information about what's happening there.
So why were tools not developed at the time to
include X and Y? Well, it's a computational challenge and sort of a
development algorithmic challenge.
And at a time where it was really important to discover things on
the vast majority of chromosomes, maybe there were just not enough
relevant genes on the Y chromosome.
If you recall the heat map I just showed you, the number of genes that's
ubiquitously expressed is actually relatively small.
There are highly repetitive regions on the Y chromosome, and
Lars has already alluded to the variance in size across the human
population, which is mostly driven actually by repetitive sequence on
Y. And so if you're familiar with the challenges of short read sequencing,
repetitive regions are really, really hard to resolve when mapping
those reads.
As I've shown you in the previous slides, there's homology with the X chromosome.
Again, short read sequencing, sometimes your aligner cannot decide
whether a read comes from the X chromosome or from the Y chromosome.
And as I mentioned before, X and Y in males don't have the
diploid ground state,
and thus sort of differs from the autosomes, of which, of course, we have two
copies in the normal state.
So a few years ago, Meifang Chi in my lab set to
change this by using two different methods to actually look
at Y chromosome loss in cancer. One is very simple and has
been employed by others in the field, including Dan, who
just presented this work,
is mRNA based, right? If you have a reasonably pure tumor, then just
looking at the expression of Y chromosome genes can very well tell you whether a
Y chromosome is in the sample or not.
And so here the blue curve indicates the samples that don't have Y chromosome
expression. So the expression is shifted to the left, and then we see another
peak of all the tumors or samples that have Y chromosome
expression in them.
But really the direct evidence comes from the DNA.
And so we used a method that was out there, popular for copy number calling called
Facets, and Meifang essentially hacked the methods by
employing a few tricks here. And one thing she did, she actually split
out the X chromosome, the Y chromosome, and the pseudo-autosomal
regions that are homologous regions at the tips of the
X and Y chromosome. They're so similar, they actually recombine during
meiosis, and so they literally behave like autosomes.
So there's two copies of them. And we separated them out so we wouldn't
confuse the algorithm with a sequence that was diploid versus
sequence that was haploid in the same chromosome.
And in this example here, you can see on the top, and I'm really
sad this mouse is not working.
It worked for me. I don't know.
How did you make it work?
I guess it wasn't working for Lars.
Okay. I'm sorry. I just have to describe what's on there.
So on the top, you can see the tumor normal copy ratio of a
tumor that has a Y chromosome. And so you can see the red lines indicate sort of
the average, and you can see the
lines are all in line. So we have one copy of the X chromosome, we
have one copy of the Y chromosome, and then we have one copy of each of the
PIR regions, PIR1 and PIR2. So that's a tumor that has retained its Y
chromosome. On the bottom, we have a tumor that has lost its Y chromosome,
and you can see there's one copy of the X chromosome.
There's a drop in the copy ratio compared to the normal sample that
we have. So the Y chromosome is gone.
And then for the two PIRs, you see proportional loss because one copy, of course,
is still there on the X chromosome, and then one copy is lost on the Y
chromosome.
And this is just to show you exactly what I just told you.
So when we did this, and you saw this slide before, across the Cancer Genome
Atlas, there were over 5,000 male tumors there.
We separate them by tumor types. We applied our algorithm, and
then we measured how many tumors in each tumor type have loss of Y
chromosome. And so on the left, you can see these are papillary renal cancers
or KIRP. Over 80% of these tumors have complete Y
chromosome loss. There are some other examples.
For example, esophageal cancer, the next ESCA,
over 50% of the tumors have complete Y chromosome loss in dark
blue, and then there's also a smaller fraction with sort of partial losses
or other Y chromosome alterations in this tumor.
And so you can go down the list and then
see in the middle we have uveal melanoma or UVM, which has
about 50% Y chromosome loss and nearly no other
alterations on the Y chromosome. And then also interestingly, on the other side of
the spectrum, there are some tumors that really never lose their Y
chromosomes. And that could be for a couple reasons.
Either they're very stable, such as thyroid cancers or
THCA or thymomas, or maybe
there's a benefit to holding on to the Y chromosome for these particular tumors,
and we don't really understand what exactly drives this
variability across cancer
types.So
now, you've seen the spread and I told you we don't really understand what's going
on, but what we really need to understand is where is loss of Y a
driver versus where it might be a passenger and the tumor cells don't actually
derive a fitness benefit from it, or they just simply don't care that
the Y chromosome is gone.
So the answer I'm taking away for you is, it probably depends,
and I'm going to show you a couple examples where you believe maybe it's a
driver, maybe it's a passenger. So how do we actually decide whether it's a
driver or passenger? So one theory that was put out
over a decade ago is that human chromosomes in cancer are
actually lost depending on their size. Okay?
So smaller chromosomes tend to be lost more frequently than larger
chromosomes. And that makes sense. There's just more genes on them.
Maybe the cost of losing chromosome 1 is higher than losing chromosome
22. And that's in fact the case. When we model this by looking
at chromosome losses across tumor types, and this example here is lung
squamous carcinoma, you can see that there's a negative
correlation between sort of the size and the frequency with which
it's lost. And you can see Y chromosome is on the far left.
It's one of the smallest chromosome, and I'm using not the exact size, but actually
the number of genes on the chromosome arm as sort of a proxy for its
importance or functional relevance.
And you can see that the Y chromosome kind of fits in there and probably in
lung squamous carcinomas, where there's a lot of losses, Y may be a
collateral, and it just lost because these tumors tend to lose many chromosomes.
However, we also saw some other examples, and in this case, the
papillary renal cancers, which you might recall have over 80%
of Y chromosome loss. This Y chromosome loss really stands
out among all the other chromosomes.
There's very low frequency of other chromosome loss except for the Y
chromosome. So this really hints at something special for Y
in this particular tumor type. Similarly, in uveal melanoma with
50% Y chromosome loss, there are some very well-known
other copy losses, including loss of chromosome three,
six, and one occasionally. But again, Y chromosome loss really
stands out because we don't have this sort of negative trend
between loss frequency and chromosome size or number of genes on
the chromosome arm. And so this is one indicator that in this case,
in these specific tumor types, the Y chromosome or its loss
might really be driving a fitness advantage.
So,
on the left, we would think maybe this is a passenger, and then on the right,
maybe here loss of Y is a driver.
Loss of Y is also associated with very specific point mutations.
So as you know, cancer is driven not only by copy number alterations, but
also somatic point mutations in various genes.
And so the first thing that we observed is loss of Y occurs frequently
when the tumor also has a p53 mutation.
And that makes sense because once you lose p53 functionality,
the tumor genome becomes unstable, and now lots of chromosome
alterations happen, including loss of chromosome Y.
So again, now my conclusion from this is if a tumor or tumor type very
frequently has p53 mutations, a loss of Y might be a
consequence of this rather than an original driver.
Now, that's not to say that loss of Y will still have a
fitness advantage in this tumor type, but it's probably consequential
to p53 loss. And I'll show you some data to actually
convince you in a little bit.
But what we also saw is that some tumor types have point mutations on
the X chromosome in genes linked to the X chromosome, including
KDM6A and KDM5C, with homologues on the Y chromosome.
And so in these cases, we have two hits.
We have the hit on the X chromosome through a point mutation, then we have loss of
the copy on the Y chromosome, and essentially that will get rid of these
two tumor suppressors.
So now how can I convince you that maybe p53 and loss of
Y are related and will give us some indication of whether it's a driver or
passenger? To get at this question, we performed a clonality
analysis. So if we think about tumor evolution, all tumors
start out from the zygote originally.
Over the lifespan, they acquire some truncal mutations,
including at some point, maybe p53, but lots of passenger mutations
as well. And so these will show up in 100% of the cells
of the tumor that grows out eventually.
Now, over time of tumor evolution, once the tumor is established, we
also acquire a subclonal mutation.
So there might be a mutation in only 30% of the cells or another
mutation that we find in 70% of the cells.
And through genomic sequencing, we can actually resolve these mutations and when
they occur during tumor evolution.
So when we did this for p53 mutations and loss of Y in
the TCGA cancer data set, we could rank them based
on when they occurred. So in this plot, we have p53
mutation clonality, or measured as the cancer cell fraction.
So the number of cancer cells that actually has this variant
in red. And then we have the cancer cell fraction of loss
of Y in blue. And you can see on the far left in uveal
melanoma, that actually p53 mutations are extremely rare.
And in this data set, we didn't have any.
Yet loss of Y has really high cancer cell fraction, meaning it's
clonal in these tumors and it's a truncal and early event.
So this is probably a driver in this particular disease.
Now, as you move to the right, you can see that p53 mutations, and of course this
is known, tend to be clonal, so their cancer cell fraction is very close to
one.
These are initiating events, or at least very early events.
And then the distribution of loss of Y cancer cell fraction tends to be
broad and also less. So what does this mean?
This means that as a p53 mutation existed earlier, and then
we ended up with a spread of loss of Y as the tumor progressively lost
Y chromosomes in the cells, caused by p53
absence.And I'm just highlighting the two that I
talked to you about before, uveal melanoma and then the lung
squamous carcinoma. Again, early P53 mutations and then
sort of loss of Y as a spread in a subclonal fashion.
So what is most important is can loss of Y tell us about
outcome? You've seen from previous talks that it's just a case for loss of Y in the
blood and in bladder cancer. And when we looked at this in the TCJ, we
also found some tumor types where loss of Y is strongly associated with
outcome. That includes uveal melanoma, where
patients whose tumors had loss of
Y really showed a much poorer outcome than those whose tumors
retained the Y chromosome, prostate cancer, where there's very
few loss of Y cases actually in primary tumors.
It increases with metastasis, but in primary tumors it's rare.
Again, these
patients had much worse outcome, and the same is true for mesothelioma,
again, where loss of Y tumors
tend to predict that the patient will do worse than if their tumors retain their Y
chromosome.
So we end up showing, and this is published work, and I'm not going to
have time to go into this, but we also showed for uveal melanoma that there's an
association with aggressiveness, rate of
metastasis, other aggressiveness markers, including EMT,
and other predictive features in uveal melanoma, and yes,
I will not have time to go into this as it's published.
So
I want to actually spend some time on new and unpublished work today.
So all of what I've shown you from the TCGA was based on exome
sequencing. We have recently, in a collaboration with Gaddy Getz at the Broad
Institute and Intercross, a company based here in San Diego,
performed analysis of whole genome sequencing from the Cancer Genome Atlas.
So these are really, really nice high-quality whole genomes,
with PCR-free whole sequencing.
And what this allows us to do now is to go beyond the protein coding genes
on the Y chromosome. What can we do with this?
We can resolve structural variations, we can start looking at non-coding
alterations, and we can also get increased coverage of protein coding
genes. And so in an early discovery here, and that's
this work done by Luis Corchete Sanchez, who is here, and if you're
interested in this, please go and check out his poster,
shows that actually many tumors have structural variants that involve the Y
chromosome. Over 30% in sarcomas, which might not be
surprising because they tend to be genopically unstable, but
also 25% in bladder cancer and high percentage in other
tumor types have structural variations, interactions, large-scale
genomic aberrations on the Y chromosome.
These can be broken down into different types. So there are deletions.
These deletions are not loss of Y. These are smaller deletions or partial
deletions of Y chromosome segments.
We have tandem duplications, inversions, but the largest chunk of
alterations on the Y chromosome involve interchromosomal
rearrangements. So that means part of the Y chromosome is attached to some
other part of the genome, some autosomes, or potentially the X
chromosome. And I'm just going to show you one example.
This is from the prostate cancer cohort.
You can see the Y chromosome on the bottom, and all these lines
show a structural variation where some part of the Y
chromosome goes to another part in the genome.
There's a lot of activity beyond just loss of Y
that's going on in these cancer genomes.
What's interesting is when Luis checked whether loss of
Y co-occurred with some of these structural variations, we
saw something very interesting, and I want to make a couple of points here in this
particular graph. So the light blue shows just loss of Y, so the whole
chromosome is gone. And this is a very important point to make, is
that the most frequent alteration involving the Y chromosome in
cancer is its entire loss. And this will have implications for how we
think about Y chromosome loss because it's not maybe just one gene or
maybe two genes, or a small region.
There seems to be some benefit to really getting rid of the whole thing in
its entirety. However, we did see loss of Y, even complete
loss of Y with some structural alterations, which are the dark
blue blocks. And now how can you get this situation, right?
You lose the Y chromosome. How can you also have a structural variation
including a Y chromosome? Now, there are multiple explanations
for this. So, for example, they could occur in the same cells if it's a
partial loss of the Y chromosome and then some other part, however small,
is attached to another chromosome.
They could occur in the same cell after whole genome doublings.
A lot of tumors double their genomes. That leads to two Y chromosomes.
One Y chromosome could be lost, and then the other one, or a part of it, could be
attached to another autosome, potentially.
And then they could just be different alterations and different tumor subclones.
I've shown you that loss of Y tends to be subclonal in many tumor types.
So you can have loss of Y in some part of the tumor, and another clone might
have a structural variant moving part of the Y chromosome elsewhere.
And as I mentioned, Luis has a poster. This is the number.
Please go check it out. He will be presenting on Monday from 9:00 to 12:00.
So now I'm going to shift gears slightly
and talk a little bit about a study that we're working on, on loss of Y
in pediatric tumors. Why is this a really important field?
You've heard a lot about how loss of Y is associated with aging, how
as men age, the Y chromosome gets lost.
In fact, I didn't have time to talk about it, but we also saw some aging
association for loss of Y
in tumors.
Now, we wanted to know if we see loss of Y in pediatric
tumors where we have no influence of aging long-term
effects or exposures to smoking over a long time,
if we could still see Y chromosome loss, and it would tell us whether it's a
driver.
So this is work done by Pracheeta Dave,
Andre Leschziner, and Teo Rivera-Vilhs, who is also here and also has a
poster that I encourage you to check out.So we took the Open
PedCan cohort, which is already pre-processed, and looked at their copy number
and checked for Y chromosome losses.
You can see here ranked in blocks by the number of tumors in each tumor
type and in the copy number heat map, you can see the dark blue indicates
loss of Y. So what's interesting and actually concordant with adult tumors is
that gliomas tend to hold onto their Y chromosomes.
They very rarely lose Y chromosomes.
However, second, we found that neuroblastoma is a tumor
type that has very frequent Y chromosome loss.
And you can see there's other tumor types, including medulloblastoma and some on
the right that are less resolved, but there are some tumor types in
children that really have Y chromosome loss we cannot explain with
aging or smoking exposure.
So overall, in this cohort, about 18% of the tumors had Y
chromosome loss. That compares to about 30% to 40% among adult
tumors, and as I said, it cannot be explained by sort of
age or other
environmental exposures, so potentially in
these diseases, it would be a driver.
So this is just to quantify. We saw a loss of Y in about 25% of
neuroblastoma, so it's a really frequent alteration.
And what was interesting is that it's associated with higher tumor stage.
So most of the loss of Y tumors are stage four, which is the worst stage.
And, if you know anything about neuroblastoma,
MYCN focal amplification is one of the most
frequent events that's also a poor prognosis predictor.
And we found that MYCN amplification actually tends to be mutually exclusive
with loss of Y. So what does this mean?
Loss of Y is associated with stage four and poor outcome,
but it's not overlapping with MYCN.
So there seem to be two different mechanisms potentially arriving at the
same biology. We don't know at this point, but just sort
of putting another high-risk factor with loss of Y
on the map in a pediatric cancer type.
So if you're interested in learning more about this,
please go and see Teo's poster.
All right. There he goes.
Okay. So finally, I want to end up with just a little bit of
relevance, therapeutic relevance.
In the end, we want to cure cancer, and loss of Y may actually
present a specific vulnerability of how we can do that.
And to give you some early data here, we used
data from the DepMap from the Broad Institute, which is actually an
experiment knocking out genes across 1,000 cell lines, so
genome-wide
knockout of all the genes. And what were we looking for?
So we're looking for situations where you have a gene on the Y
chromosome in blue, and then the same gene homologue might be on
the X chromosome, and that X chromosome gene is knocked out in this
experiment. What can we see in cells that have loss of Y
versus those cell lines that retain their Y chromosomes?
When we did this experiment, we found that actually in
loss of Y cell lines, there are two genes linked to the X chromosome
that are very, very strong dependencies.
So that means if you knock out the gene DDX3X
or EIF1AX, and the cells don't have a Y
chromosome to back up these genes, those cells die frequently.
So that gives us a first idea of what the things are that we could target
related to the X chromosome in loss of Y cells to potentially
attack cancer cells that have loss of Y.
All right.
And with this, I just want to summarize.
I've told you that somatic Y chromosome alterations are common across cancer
types. As I said, 30% to 40% across adult tumors, about
20% in pediatric tumors. Whole chromosome loss of Y compared to
other alterations is the most frequent
alteration of the Y chromosome, and its frequency varies a lot.
Loss of Y is associated with genomic instability, and particularly mutations or
loss of P53. It's associated with clinical features,
including outcome, at least in some tumor types.
However, we don't fully understand the exact driver mechanisms,
especially as they might vary between different tumor types.
And so I just want to go to a few open challenges that I encourage you to think
about or maybe talk to us and bring the field forward.
So the structure of the Y chromosome, as Lars has said, actually varies
substantially between individuals, ranging from 45 megabases to
over 80 megabases. But we're currently using only the reference
genome, which is about 62 megabases, right?
So what are we really missing there? What's variability between individuals?
Short-read sequencing cannot represent Y variation fully, and
that's just a limitation, that it doesn't account for all this length and
variability in the repeat frequencies.
One question I get frequently is, well, is Y simply
dispensable? The cells don't care.
I hope all three of us convinced you otherwise.
Is there a common phenotype of loss of Y in cancer, or does it
vary between tumor types? Again, something we don't fully understand yet.
And then how do mosaic loss of Y as it occurs in the blood and tumor loss
of Y relate? You already heard a little bit about this, but again, we're
still very early in understanding those interactions between the immune
system and the tumor. And with that, I'd like to thank you
for listening and coming. My lab, of course, Luis and
Teo, who are here and will present posters on this topic.
Meifang, I mentioned before, who wrote the algorithm.
Our collaborators at the Broad Institute, Gaddy Getz's lab, and Intercross for
the whole genome study, my funding sources, and of course, all the
participants and donors who make this research really possible.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Now, okay.
Beautiful work, Esther.
Can you say something about the role of negative selection
in this, and whether you did analysis that could
support the
high prevalence of Y loss in cases where you do suspect it
to be driver is also related to the much
lower negative selection against its loss?
So it's not dispensable, but clearly comparison to other autosomes.
So for example, if you have a driver gene that
it's beneficial for the cancer to lose it, the whole chromosome loss
is just a very easy way for the cancer to achieve it, and it cannot be
achieved, let's say, with a large autosome.
Right. So that's a very interesting question.
We have not really looked much at negative selection.
I think that would be a good thing to do, and I'm happy to talk to you about this.
One thing that's really cool about the Y chromosome also in terms of selection and
as a therapeutic target is you can get it back. Right?
And I think, yeah, let's chat. I think that's a great idea. Thank you.
Hi, Esther. Great talk.
Thanks.
So,
you showed on that one slide where there are different
ways that you can have loss of Y. You could have the whole loss of Y, or you could
have partial and things like that subclonal or maybe after
a copy number event. But you also showed that even though it was
a small percentage, there are also some gain of the Y
chromosome. Now, have you looked at
the clonal dynamics, let's say, a cell lost, like a
loss of Y, but then the subclone gain a copy or something, and how
does that change the fitness of the
cancer cell?
We have not looked at this since these data are relatively fresh, but that's
definitely something we want to do, especially in cells or tumors that
have multiple alterations. How do they
line up during tumor evolution in time?
What other events might prompt one event or the other?
So, yes, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for your great talk.
I have one question regarding how the loss of
Y
is linked to the drug resistance. So I wonder
if you looked into the loss of Y status
for the second-line or third-line patients to
see if
any
enrichment in loss of Y or any depletion in loss of
Y,
and
whether it relates to the specific therapeutic regimen.
Yeah, that's a great question. We have not done this.
Partially, it relates to the fact that we need rather big
data sets to make some statistically robust
conclusions, and it's very difficult to do that for
especially third-line therapy because the heterogeneity in
patient exposure to therapies is very high.
I think definitely something we'd like to do as there's more data that becomes
available from clinical trials and large sequencing
studies, I think we'll be able to do that, and we'll be able to tell
whether there's differences in response and then maybe
also resistance that's related to loss of Y. Absolutely.
Actually, we've done that. And
so
there are caveats, obviously, with the lines of therapy.
But there's definitely a pattern to response and to the
acquisition of the LOY or deepening of the LOY or
changing of the LOY with therapeutics.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
I was going to say there's a question on the internet, but okay.
Go ahead.
Loss of Y chromosomes in this patient is associated with this
cancer,
in that patient with that cancer.
One potential simple explanation, it depends on their genetics
predisposition for this cancer or that cancer.
So has anyone done PRS analysis
to see if there's any association between the genetics of that
person and the cancer that was induced by
LOY?
There are studies that have
shown association of loss of Y in the blood and
certain cancers, as Lars has shown.
I'm not aware of germline
and
tumor manifestation of loss of Y, but they're probably related.
I would guess that if there's p53 mutation or potentially
CHEK2, things that impact overall genomic
instability will impact the probability of
losing the Y chromosome in a tumor as well.
So there's one question on the internet.
Have you
looked at maternalization of Y chromosome?
Loss of Y is expected to be the result of inefficient maternalization of the Y
chromosome, which is a fundamental biological concept.
As such, LOY is a passenger event. What do you think?
Good question. I really don't know, but that's something we should think about.
And it's definitely a probability that loss of Y might
be a passenger, at least in some tumor types.
Okay. Well, we finished right on time.
Thank you, everybody, and thank you to the speakers.
Thank you. Thank you again.